hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation using human stem cells to
model neocortical gyration phenotypes
presented by ashley schaeffer
assistant professor in the department of
genetics and genome sciences at Case
Western Reserve University I'm Kate out
of thermo Fisher Scientific and I will
be your moderator for today's
presentation before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive so we encourage you to
participate by submitting any questions
you have at any time during the
presentation all you have to do is click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
question into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen so answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please also use the
extra question box to let us know now
please allow me to introduce Ashley
Schaeffer Ashley graduated with a BS in
genetics from University of Wisconsin
Madison and went on to earn her PhD from
the University of California Irvine
under the mentorship of dr. Micah sander
she continues her training as a
postdoctoral fellow at the University of
California San Diego and Howard Hughes
Medical Institute under the guidance of
dr. Joseph G Gleeson where she focused
on elucidating the genetic cause and
molecular mechanisms underlying
recessive pediatric neurological disease
during her time with dr. Gleason Ashley
discovered over twenty novel genetic
causes of disease many full recesses
syndromic pediatric neurodegenerative
disorders she joined the department of
genetics and genomics Sciences at Case
Western Reserve University as an
assistant professor in February of last
year I will now turn the presentation
over to her Ashley thank you I'd like to
start by thanking Thermo Fisher and the
organizers of the event for giving me
the opportunity to talk about our use of
human stem cells to understand
neurological disease mechanisms I'd like
to start by drawing attention to these
different brains on this slide you can
see that Drosophila mouse and human
brain have very distinct key features
that result from differences in
development the most obvious difference
is the size of the brains while another
is the presence of cortical folding or
gyration pattern this feature develops
from radial unit hypothesis so neural
progenitor cells proliferate and give
rise to intermediate progenitor cells
which can transiently amplify and
differentiate into neurons that migrate
out of the cortical plate to establish
and integrate circuits
you might notice from this review that
humans have an additional cell type not
commonly found within the mouse brain
called the outer radial glial cells
these cells can also proliferate greatly
expanding the number of neurons that can
develop from a single ventricular
progenitor cell
vision due to these differences in brain
development certain human disorders are
not well modeled in mice Here I am
showing an image of a chronal adult
mouse brain section the mouse on the
left is wild-type and the mouse on the
right has a homozygous mutation in C KD
v ra p2 which is a known causative gene
for primary microcephaly the bottom
panels are zoomed in image showing very
little phenotypic difference between
mice with and without this human
disease-causing gene mutation in
contrast in the panel on the right
Madeleine Lancaster from the nobley
cloud developed an induced pluripotent
stem cells from patients with primary
microcephaly that have mutations in this
very same gene when she differentiated
them to cerebral organoids or mini
brains she saw in clear phenotype in the
dish the patient mutation impaired
proliferation of neuronal progenitor
cells and led to precocious
differentiation this result suggests
that animal models might not be a
suitable choice to study all types of
human disease and that using stem cells
may be a valid alternative approach so
to use stem cells as a disease model
there are typically two approaches that
we use the first is to develop induced
pluripotent stem cells from patients
that have a specific disorder this
method is particularly useful when the
genetic cause of the disorder is not yet
understood or for complex genetic
disorders with many contributing
variants the disadvantages include
differences in the genetic background
between the samples tend to lead to
large experimental valuation the second
approach is to use human embryonic stem
cell lines and use a genome editing
technology like CRISPR cap 9 to
introduce to these causing variants this
method is useful when the genetic cause
of the disorder is defined and only
consists of a few mutations or of a
specific haplotype by introducing these
mutations into the stem cells using gene
technology we can create isogenic stem
cell lines in this case the genetic
background of the experiment is tightly
controlled and we expect to see less
experimental variation we can then use
these stem cells to develop neuronal
cells using well-established
differentiation protocols we can make
organoids
and we can also make pure populations of
neurons that can be used for biochemical
analysis so now I'm going to tell you
about a story where we applied stem cell
modeling to understand a neurological
disorder that could not be well modeled
in mice listen subtly it's a
developmental disorder that's caused by
defects in neural migration in this
simplified coronal image of a human
brain affected individuals present with
a smoothening of the cerebral cortex
upon MRI imaging this is referred to as
packaged area or AG Riya most patients
also have mental retardation and early
onset of intractable seizures
listen Cecily is a very rare condition
but it's usually genetic with roughly
90% of all patients having mutations in
one of the three common lists encephalo
causing genes list one tubulin or DC X
which I'll talk more about in a couple
of slides so let's listen safley is not
well modeled in mice deletion of known
list encephalo causing genes like DC X
does not produce a cortical phenotype
initially it was hypothesized that mice
might have added redundancy so
researchers decided to use shrnas to try
to knock down multiple isoforms to study
migration unfortunately we now know that
shrnas can also induce neuronal
migration defects on their own by dis
regulating the micro RNA processing
pathway in neurons so as I mentioned in
the introduction neurons are produced at
the apical surface of the brain through
asymmetric cell division of neural
progenitor cells or glial cells the
faded neurons migrate in an outward
fashion and they populate each layer of
the court
in a temporal manner to produce a
six-layer cortex when you have aberrant
migration you end up with a smooth
thickened four layer cortex and patients
with listen subtly have this feature so
neuronal migration has been studied for
decades in animal models but only
recently have we been able to link human
mutations to elicit ugly phenotype in
this structure of a basic bipolar
translocating neuron we can identify
various mutations that affect a variety
of processes for instance mutations in
reelin VLDL are and APR 2 2016 7 hypo
morphic mutations in the tubulin
proteins which are the structural
proteins that make up microtubules have
been shown to cause a cinder ohmic
patient phenotypes with packaged area
the first gene mutations in patients
with less encephalo were in the genes
list one or a deletion of the tip of
chromosome 17 which causes a disorder
called miller Dieker syndrome as well as
the DC x gene which causes listen safley
and sub and cortical heterotopia this
class of proteins in the gray box
controls microtubule dynamics and
function in nuclear translocation during
migration so as you can see from this
image taken from a review by builder
bonds each gene and mutation types
creates a unique form of listen subtly
that can be clinically categorized by
anterior to posterior gradient as well
as the severity of cortical smoothening
i want to note that you can sometimes
guess what the affected gene will be
based on patient MRIs because DC X
mutations always cause an anterior to
posterior gradient and list one or
Miller Dieker syndrome deletions always
cause a posterior to anterior gradient
when we look at patient MRIs and see
unique patterns we can be fairly certain
that a novel causative gene on
lies the patient disorder so to identify
new causative genes for pediatric
cortical phenotypes we start our
research pipeline by recruiting patients
with interesting phenotypes like unique
MRI findings in this case we can then
perform exome or genome sequencing to
identify new causative genes or find
candidate variants that might underlie
the disorder we then perform functional
assays to assess the pathogenicity of
the variant and determine the mechanism
of disease we will take this information
from the lab and work with our
collaborating physicians to reassess
patient treatment options improve
disease classifications and better
define clinical syndromes using this
approach we identified three families
with a unique MRI showing a diffused
Tyron of packaged area with cortical
thickening up to ten times its normal
thickness patients had a thin corpus
callosum varying degrees of cerebellar
hypoplasia and a complete absence of the
anterior commissure sequencing and bound
formatic analysis found a shared region
of homozygosity on chromis chromis ohm -
within all large homozygous blocks very
few variants passed our threshold for
further analysis and CT n na - was found
mutated in all patients further the
affected individuals had all had very
severe homozygous mutations as the C
terminal end of the protein so we
predict that alpha uncut Ihnen mutations
are positive for the patient's phenotype
alpha and Catina is encoded by the gene
CTN na - there are three alpha catenin
pair labs and humans with varying
degrees of similarity the Katainen
proteins are most similar to vinculin
family proteins and shares three
vinculin homology domains alpha ii
catenin is the most widely expressed and
is found within epithelial tissues where
it's required for epithelial integrity
and polarity
it has also been widely studied also T
catenin is 55% homologous with alpha and
Catina and is expressed within the heart
and the testes so in human tissue
we found CT n na - is predominantly
expressed in neurons and at a low level
within neural progenitor cells so
similar to what I showed you for known
list especially disease genes ECX a
couple slides back the alpha catenin
knockout and spawn es spontaneous alpha
catenin mutant mice have been generated
and do not display a cortical phenotype
by growth histological examination brdu
birth dating during neurogenesis also
showed a normal number of neurons are
created and migrate to the proper
location within the cerebral cortex
therefore we decided we needed to create
a human in vitro listen Cecily disease
model to understand how patients with
these mutations develop the disorder we
generated IPS L clones from one affected
and one unaffected individual from one
of our families with CT n na - mutations
we also developed ICS else from a
patient with unknown mutation that
causes Miller Dieker syndrome as a
control and we also created three
isogenic also gatina knockout h9 DSL
lines that we use also as an additional
control so to assess migration we
modified a traditional neuro spirit a
protocol the way the protocol works is
you dissociate adherent npcs to create
neurospheres we then remove the STS to
induce differentiation two days later we
can place the neurospheres on PLO
laminin or maître gel coded place or
slides and then two days after plating
we can assess the distance that the
neuronal cell bodies migrate away from
the edge of the neuro sphere to quantify
neuronal migration we then performed as
a say on control patients as well as
patients with Miller deeper syndrome
deletions and patients with
like a teaming variance as well as our
knockout NPCs similar to what was
recently shown in the 3d organoid model
of Miller Dieker syndrome from Tony
winch a Boris's lab we found roughly 55%
of neurons in the Miller Decker syndrome
patients did not migrate farther than
100 micrometers after 48 hour period
also gatina and mutant cells showed a
similar distribution of migration
distances and cellular phenotypes in
vitro suggesting that our model is
representative of the patient phenotype
of Liston safley and could be a useful
tool to better understand the disorder
we next image the neurons during
migration and found the alpha catenin
mutant neurons showed very unstable
primary neurites and collapsed
frequently impeding their migration the
affected cells also showed a thickened
shortener ice with proximal ectopic
philip odeon lamellipodia their growth
cones were wide and heavily branched
compared to controls this phenotype and
migration could be restored by
reintroducing also Catina an expression
in the mutant cells using a lentiviral
rescue vector this results showed that
these phenotypes were specifically due
to the loss of alpha and Catina so Natsu
wanted to use these cells to study the
disease mechanism the homolog of alpha
and Catina and alpha ii continent has
been well studied in epithelial tissues
and has been shown to regulate beta
catenin target gene expressions binds
beta catenin and cad hiren to control
epithelial adhesion bind and bundle
actin filaments as well as inhibit r23
polymerization activity therefore we
wanted to test whether any of these
cellular processes were disrupted in the
alpha catenin mutant cells we first
assessed beta catenin signaling by
performing RNA seek on npcs from miller
Dieker syndrome and also Catina and
mutant patient cells we found very few
transcriptional differences which mostly
appeared to be due to the genetic
background of the patients rather than
an effect of alpha catenin on
transcription to be sure we also checked
wint target gene expression by qrt-pcr
with and without went 3a stimulation and
found no significant differences in
expression this suggests that alpha and
catenin
does not regulate win signaling in npcs
alpha eco tannin also binds to beta
catenin to control cell adhesion and
polarity so we wanted to test whether
loss of alpha and Catina altered neural
epithelial structures so we developed
neural rosette
from our control and alpha catenin
patient NPCs and assess the presence of
apical markers of polarity we found
normal expression of tight Junction
markers EO 1 and the adherence Junction
markers of encode hearin and beta
catenin in addition the rosettes showed
a symmetrically localized primary cilia
at the apical surface together these
results suggest that alpha catenin does
not adversely affect neural epithelial
polarity or integrity in culture so the
last thing we wanted to check was
whether alpha and Catina and played a
role in actin regulation we first tested
whether alpha and Catina can bind to and
bundle F abdun so we use purified
proteins and performed an actin binding
and bundling assay at high speeds
polymerized actin is pelleted while
alpha n catenin is found in the
supernatant but when alpha and Catina is
added to us actin it binds and comes
down in the pellet similarly under a
lower speed as actin is predominantly
found in a super named as alpha and
Catina when Elsa and catenin is added to
us actin it binds and bundles up actin
to increase the amount of f-actin in the
pellet which now also contains alpha and
Catina so now that we know that alpha
and Catina can find and bundle actin we
want to determine whether the loss of
this function is leading to our cellular
phenotype but first I need to describe
how act is regulated in the cell before
going into further detail so
extracellular stimuli control D plumbers
ation of actin filaments by controlling
the activity of cofilin which cleaves us
actin to form g actin monomeric actin is
poised for polymerization by binding to
profilin and ATP external stimuli
activate wasp which when bound to r23
serves as an actin nucleating factor to
form branched actin g actin can be added
to the plus end by foreman proteins to
elongate actin filaments capping /
teens can find also to these plus ends
and inhibit form and mediated actin
polymerization so the process of actin
polymerization and depolymerization is
called tread milling so the majority of
molecules that regulate actin
polymerization and disassembly are the
same in neurons as other cell types but
there are some additional specialized
players in neurons in neurons actin is
predominantly found within the growth
cone bundled actin filaments create
protrusions called Filip Odia and
branched actin networks create
lamellipodia and the actin arcs that are
found in the transitional zone at the
base of the growth cone which is
necessary to control microtubule
advanced during neuronal translocation
and migration based upon the cellular
phenotype of the patient migrating
neurons we suspected that actin
branching and bundling may be miss
regulated when alpha catenin is mutated
but to specifically test whether a
direct alpha and Catina active
interaction was necessary for neural
migration we created a couple of
lentiviral constructs the first is alpha
and catenin lacking the actin binding
domain which is circled in green the
second construct is just the actin
binding domain of alpha and Catina
which is circled in red we transduced
the npcs and performed the neuro spear
as a in control and alpha catenin
knockout cells to measure migration the
presence of the the presence of the
actin binding domain was necessary to
rescue migration and we also found that
the expression of the actin binding
domain in alpha and Catina was
sufficient to rescue migration the
mutant cells and it also induced
migration in the control cells
suggesting that this domain of alpha and
Catina
mediates migration so since alpha and
catenin could regulate actin in a
variety of ways we wanted to test
whether it was capable
repressing r23 mediated active branching
so we performed an art to three mediated
actin polymerization assay using
purified proteins we can induce act and
branching and polymerization by adding
our two three and is activating protein
and wasps which is shown with the green
line without our two three basal levels
of actin polymerization is observed and
this is the black line but when we add
alpha and Catina in a dose-dependent
matter we can observe a stepwise
reduction in the amount of art to three
mediated actin polymerization shown in
red lines so this suggests that alpha
and catenin can inhibit r23 mediated
actin branching to regulate actin
structure this occurs without
interfering with global F actin
polymerization since the ratio of
monomeric to polymerize actin is
unchanged so this suggests that alpha
and catenin
regulates specifically the ratio of
branched and bundled actin filaments in
neurons if alpha catenin regulates r23
mediated actin branching we wanted to
next assess whether our patient cells
had increased amounts of the arc to
three complex associated with their
actin filaments so we performed an actin
affinity pulldown and measured the
levels of ARP 3 which is one of the
proteins that binds and gets
incorporated into the actin filaments
during act and branching we found almost
a two-fold increase in the amount of ARP
3 associated with actin this suggests
that our patient cells has more actin
branches or has more art to three
complex bound to their actin filaments
so if the actin binding domain of alpha
and Catina mediates this we should be
able to reverse this effect by
expressing just the actin binding domain
of alpha and Catina
so when we performed the same assay in
the knockout neurons with and without
the active binding domain we found
expression of the actin binding domain
was sufficient to potently block this
interaction in vivo to show this was
direct we also performed an arc to three
mediated polymerization assay and found
a dose-dependent decrease in actin
branching in the presence of alpha and
Katinas so our results thus far would
predict that inhibition of r23 would
rescue the cellular patient's phenotype
so to confirm our model we identified
two different cell permeable small
molecule inhibitors of the arc two three
complex proteins after a dosing curve
when added to patient neurons for 48
hours they completely restored aneroid
length of alpha catenin mutant but not
the miller deeper syndrome cells this
result suggests that r23 overactivity
underlies the neuronal phenotype in our
patients
so in summary of what I've showed you
thus far today animal models have
significant differences in brain
development that may make them
unsuitable models for certain human
disorders and diseases
a viable alternative has been proven to
accurately model human brain disorders
is the use of human very potent stem
cells which have their own distinct
advantages and disadvantages these cells
can be used to both identify disease
mechanisms as well as test therapeutic
candidates to treat these devastating
brain disorders
I also showed you an example of three
families that had a unique brain
disorder of package Iria we used an
exome sequencing approach and find by
allelic mutations in alpha and Catina we
also used a human stem cell based
disease model to test for neuronal
migration defects and also identify the
underlying disease mechanisms we found
that alpha and patinas main function in
neural migration was to inhibit r23
mediated act and branching without which
leads to defective migration we also
showed that loss of alpha and catenin
did not affect neural epithelial cell
polarity or impact with signaling
activity within the neurons therefore in
our model we predict that alpha and
Catina normally binds to and bundles
f-actin
which controls r23 branching and the
confirmation of actin during neuronal
migration when alpha catenin is deleted
we have excessive r23 binding and ACT
and branching occurring this reduces the
stability of the actin cytoskeleton
Network by preventing bundled act
information therefore when r23 is
repressed in the alpha catenin mutant
cells we can block actin branching and
this allows restoration of actin
bundling through other protein
interactions and the formation of a
stable f-actin network so lastly I want
to thank all the people that
participated in this study in particular
the research participants that shared
their clinical data and donated samples
that made this work possible as well as
members of my lab who perform the work
and members of the Gleason lab which is
located at UCSD who contributed to our
findings
clinical collaborators that have been
instrumental in patient recruitment and
phenotype interpretation and our funding
sources for this study and thank you I'd
be happy to take any questions that you
might have
all right Thank You Ashley very much for
the informative presentation we now
begin the last Q&A portion of the
webinar again if you have a question
that you'd like to ask Ashley please do
so now you can click on the ask a
question drop-down box located in the
far left of your presentation window and
then type the question in and then click
the send button okay we do have a couple
questions the first one is about your
stem cell models did you find any
difficulty with any particular starting
cell population like any characteristics
it says you may have that may have led
to the differences for example patient
specific differences well luckily for
this project alpha and catenin
is exclusively expressed in neurons and
so it's not expressed in stem cells
therefore the stem cells that we
generated from the patient's did not
have any defects associated with the
loss of this protein we did notice later
when we were developing our neuronal
cells that there was a bit of variation
from line to line we had to be very
careful to make sure that we used
neuronal cells that were derived from
the same set of differentiation as well
as neuronal cells that were roughly a
similar passage number because they seem
to once they begin to differentiate or
they're a little older we found that
removal of the FDF increased like
basically the speed at which they
matured varied depending on the passage
number of the npc's that we were using
so we had to be very careful to use
representative samples that were
processed in parallel but we didn't
notice anything that was specific to the
gene mutation itself okay
all right next question if you could
have any characteristics about your stem
cell model be it biologically feasible
or not what would it be
if we could have way I'm sorry okay it's
okay if you could have any
characteristics about your stem cell
model be it biologically feasible or not
but would it be
I think
that you know what was great about the
model that we really love compared to
some other models that might be
available is the speed at which you can
conduct a research and discover the
answers and we greatly appreciate the
ability to take ICS cells and be able to
turn them into any almost any cell types
of the body there's wonderful
differentiation protocols to be able to
produce many different types of neurons
as well as supporting cells for the
nervous system and so this has really
been a huge asset to neuroscience
research in general and has really
increased the speed at which we can
discover these disease mechanisms and
figure out what's going on in these
patient disorders so I would say
probably the speed yes okay does your
research have any implications into
pediatric patients yeah so I think a lot
of these patients you know these
specific ones that I talked about today
they have they have very severe
mutations in alpha and Catina but this
gene has also been linked to other
neuropsychiatric disorders like
intellectual disabilities schizophrenia
and it's possible that the same disease
mechanisms that we discovered with
disease families are also occurring
within these patients with other types
of disorders just maybe in not a severe
of manner so what we like to think of is
that we can use these very severe cases
of patients with structural brain
defects to really learn about biological
mechanisms and pathway dysregulation and
that this knowledge can be used to
develop therapeutics for patients that
have similar disease mechanisms but may
not the same exact mutation but maybe
the same pathway as being dysregulated
and so we think that our research would
be applicable to a broad set of patients
with neurological disorders in general
okay that's wonderful 30 okay just had
another question come in can patient
solving phenotypes be recapitulated well
in organoid model so there's been some
work from Tony Winship orestes lab which
is also a case looking at cerebral
organoids studying Miller Dieker
syndrome which has the complete loss of
folding I believe some of the mechanisms
that they find our most easy to model
has been changes in cell number as well
as looking at migration in the organoid
itself under not really observing a
folding pattern differences because the
organoids are very variable
I believe in their structure so it's
difficult to have a recapitulate the
same folding structure over multiple
organ oeid so you can study the
underlying mechanisms of the loss of the
folding but to actually observe the
folding happen in an organelle is I
think not yet possible okay
okay we have another one here do you
find neurodegeneration in any other
mechanism which occurs with as much
prevalence as the migration patterns
yeah so okay in this disorder we don't
anticipate that there is neuro
degeneration but we know from the field
that neurodegenerative diseases are much
more common within the population then
listen Cecily there are some instances
of microcephaly with also gyration
defects that can be due to a
degenerative mechanism or loss of
neuronal cells during development or
postnatally but we
the the migration is very the migration
pattern is very specific and also very
rare condition in humans
okay
okay I got another one do you think
please I hope I say this correctly do
you think package Iria and poly
microsphere you share common mechanisms
I believe that they do share that a
common mechanism of a migration defect
I can't I have not seen a situation
necessarily where patients have the same
gene mutated but have a diagnosis of
probably my criteria or package area so
I'm not I'm not sure that the same genes
are going to be identified but the clear
underlying mechanism in both disorders
is impaired neural migration
okay and
their questions based on the mouse
versus human modeling could it mean that
the mechanisms of neural migration
diseases differ between rodents and
humans that's a really good question I
think I I think we don't know that much
yet about migration in human only
recently have we been able to really
look at human neurons migrating in a
dish there's been some great work out of
Arnold Christine's lab using viral
approaches to look at migration and how
they migrate there's been a couple
prevailing hypotheses about why you know
we can make these mice that have these
human mutations and they don't really
have a phenotype and one is that that
there could be this genetic redundancy
right which I talked about and that's
still unknown because we know that
there's a lot of genes that are human
specific we also know that mice don't
have all the same or the prevalence of
the same cell types within the cortex
and they don't exhibit a folded brain
structure it's also been hypothesized
that some of the difference in the brain
structure between Mouse and humans is
due to the distance that the neurons
have to migrate so within a mouse brain
the distance from the ventricular
surface to the critical plate is much
smaller than what you would see in a
human brain and so that the distance
really makes up why the phenotype is
observed in humans and not in mice but
this hasn't really been tested I think
recently people are also starting to you
know put human neurons or progenitor
cells into Mouse brains and look for
changes in migration but again we don't
know if all the cues that direct
migrating cells are present in mice and
are expressed at the same level or
present the same place as what they are
within the human brain so I think this
is an area that's going to have a lot
more focus in the future to really
understand why we don't really have any
good animal
models for a lot of these types of human
brain disorders
you
okay and actually I just a question for
me on that and just thinking about the
essays you need to do to measure
migration is it is it very difficult to
do that in Mouse cells
essays in the way that you've done them
occur human cells actually I think they
were they were done originally in Mouse
cells and that's where the essays
originated from and in that case what
you do is you take the isolated Mouse
progenitor cells and you form
neurospheres and you remove the FDS but
you you don't really have to age the
cells they mature at a different rate
than the human cells so when you
directly plate the neural progenitor
cells they can migrate out of the
neurospheres and you can see accurate
changes in migration but what's still
unknown is if you would take these npcs
from a mouse that has a mutation in
elisa cefalu gene and if you did the
same exact assay with the human cells
and the mouse cells would they act the
same or would the human cells act
differently than the mouse cells so
there hasn't really been any one that
has investigated or investigated that
phenomenon yet so I think there's still
like a lot of assays to be developed
there's also different types of
migration and neurons there's neurons
tend to migrate along the processes of
radial glial cells and so our assays are
artificial in the fact that you know
you're plating neurons on a Maitre
gelled plate and they're not migrating
along these fibers so there's also
people interested in looking at
migration along these fibers as a
different mechanism of migration than
what might be observed within these
culture systems okay
so I do have one more question here but
I just want to open it up again to the
listeners if you've got a question
please type in and we do have some time
and actually the next question was can
you tell us a little bit about your next
steps for research if you're yes yes
because you build tell us a little bit
about your next steps for your research
sure um so our lab is really focused on
trying to identify new types of
pediatric brain diseases and trying to
identify what those mechanisms are that
underlie the disorders and whether
there's any commonalities between these
different clinical syndromes and
spectrums and so we we are focused on
recruiting additional patients that
might have these pediatric brain
disorders of unknown genetic etiology
where we can help them identify the
molecular cause as well as pinpoint like
therapeutics that might be helpful for
them in the clinic and then we we like
to combine um using these cell based
models with animal models and also our
tissue culture models with using IPS
cells and their derivatives their
neuronal derivative so a lot of our
diseases are actually that we study are
actually quite well modeled in mice and
so we also try to validate our
approaches using animal models whenever
possible so we're trying to identify new
mechanisms of neuro degeneration in
children and we're trying to expand upon
some of our previous findings and learn
about whether some of these disease
mechanisms are actually common to more
prevalent disorders like autism or
intellectual disability or schizophrenia
you
all right some sounds very exciting and
there are no more questions at this time
so once again I would like to thank you
Ashley for your presentation it was
great we would love to have you back it
was great to hear you and before we go
please know everyone that today's
webinar will be available for on-demand
viewing through February of next year
and thank you all for joining us we hope
you enjoy the rest of today's event
thank you